all right despite the mountain of
evidence against suspend prosecutors
still face an uphill battle in part
because of the clinton donors in the
jury pool here now with more is fox news
contributor and george washington law
professor jonathan turley
uh professor thanks so much for joining
us here um you you've written about this
i i really appreciate your comments on
this but
what is it three of the jurors are
actually clinton donors why in the world
are they sitting in this jury pool right
well it's sort of a bizarre twist when
we guarantee you a jury of your peers we
don't mean that if you're a clinton
person you'll be tried by other clinton
people
and you can sort of feel like john duran
might might take away the lesson that
that's the case in dc
because you know 90 of people voted for
uh hillary clinton in d.c
and so the jury pool is going to be
naturally heavily weighted in that
direction but there is a difference
between a clinton supporter and a
clinton donor i mean when you're a donor
it's a much more
active role uh it's it's different from
just voting for hillary clinton so we
have three people who indicated that
they are in fact clinton donors we also
have another
person who said that she's a donor to
aoc
and had to be sort of
probed and sort of prodded
i should say to
uh
say that she was going to be actually
impartial
and
these people very well could be
impartial they could be fair certainly
clinton supporters can be fair and
impartial jurors
but when you have donors
on the jury it raises real concerns
there's also a juror by the way whose
daughter
plays on a team with sussman's daughter
and the judge said i'm going to let that
go through as well
so for john durham i think that the
impression is that you know short of
having chelsea clinton on this jury i
couldn't be doing much worse in terms of
of a jury pool
now having said all of that i don't mean
to
suggest that these jurors are going to
be
biased
they very well could be impartial jurors
take things very seriously what is very
clear at this point is that the evidence
against sussman is overwhelming i mean
sussman's text
to
baker
states very clearly i am not
representing any client
and the prosecutors have said he was and
he was billing that time to the clinton
campaign
but now that we have this bombshell of
mook
saying that hillary clinton personally
greenlighted
this effort these juror connections
become more of a concern
they certainly become more magnified
because one of the jurors was told by a
defense attorney don't worry hillary
clinton and donald trump are not on
on trial here and the juror said oh okay
then i think i really can be impartial
well
as of friday hillary clinton was very
much part of the uh
the testimony
you've also commented about the
difference between the way general flynn
was dealt with and the way uh this uh
this prosecution is going can explain to
us the difference between the two
because the judge is making very
different rulings
right well you know jason as you recall
we had a perfectly bizarre situation
with flynn uh judge emmitt sullivan
even in one hearing accused him of
basically treason using the flag in the
courtroom as a prop
and sullivan seemed to remove every
obstacle from the path of prosecutors
judge cooper
has really been
tough on the prosecution he has
narrowed the scope of evidence and of
questioning
he's made a number of rulings that the
prosecutors have
very
very much objected to and it's sort of
like an obstacle course for john durham
in that sense so he's got a tough jury
and a very tough judge
and this is in the same courtroom this
is in the same courthouse i should say
in d.c
and i think people look at those two
trials and they say wow this is a really
striking and fairly glaring
difference it's the same charge about
lying to federal investigators but you
couldn't have a greater difference in
terms of the optics in terms of these
orders
now
when you look at this and you're
analyzing again the jury pool it's in
washington d.c
do prosecutors make the mistake of
overcomplicating it because it is a very
simple one charge case here
well that's true although it is
fascinating to see what happened in the
courtroom because the defense had won
in narrowing the case cooper gave them
critical rulings told durham that he
couldn't bring in this broader context
of the clinton campaign and also the
specific data that was generated they
won those fights and then they decided
to put mook on the stand
and he became johnny the human torch
right on the stand i mean i mean all of
us have had bad experiences in court but
a few would compare to that i mean
hillary clinton there's a general rule
in washington that thou shalt not
name hillary clinton in a scandal if
you're a democrat
and this thing really violated that
commandment in d.c
mean you have mooc saying that oh this
was raised to her now keep in mind that
durham has already documented that the
researchers who put together this
material
said that they didn't think it was it
would stand up to scrutiny they said
that people could really
mock us for what we're saying here and
then hillary was reportedly told we
really don't have anything clear here
and she greenlighted it
and they gave it to slate and slate ran
with it and then we see this familiar
pattern right they get
friendly media to run it and then they
respond as if they had nothing to do
with it right so they then have you have
jake sullivan and hillary clinton
tweeting out wow look at what slate just
reported
and at the same time you have associates
pushing these uh these claims in the fbi
it's the same pattern on for both the
steele dossier and the alpha bank
scandal
yeah and you know what uh it's slate
comes out with it and they all report it
and they regurgitate it but suddenly you
have a campaign attorney in a federal
courthouse charged with a crime
and he's talking about hillary clinton
and the media are absolutely nowhere in
reporting we're going to talk about that
next jonathan turley thank you so much
for joining us tonight on hannity hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else